let's talk about Michael Flynn and a
possible pardon Donald Trump was asked
about the possibility of pardoning
indicted inane idiotic Aksum impetuous
and irresponsible former National
Security Advisor Michael Flynn and
Donald Trump certainly didn't rule it
out he used language that pretty clearly
says yeah he might pardon Michael Flynn
depending on the circumstances
here's Trump speaking to reporters
outside the White House over the weekend
would you consider a pardon for Michael
Flynn I don't want to talk about pardon
so Michael Flynn yet we'll see what
happens let's see I can say this when
you look at what's going on with the FBI
and with the Justice Department people
are very very angry thank you very much
I don't want to talk about pardons for
Flynn yet we'll see what happens and of
course the defenders have two positions
on this and they happen to be
diametrically opposed defenses one is
David you're exaggerating Trump didn't
say he's thinking about pardoning Flynn
he just said he hasn't yet really
considered it that doesn't mean he's
actually thinking about it the other
defenders of this are saying oh yeah
Trump's the president there's no reason
why he shouldn't be able to pardon
Michael Flynn pardons aren't illegal the
truth is Trump has clearly signaled that
pardons for his friends and cronies are
on the table he pardoned racists sheriff
joe arpaio in August a clear message
that Trump sent that yeah he'll pardon
people and sometimes when we report on
this stuff we get into the weeds we
missed the forest for the trees
obviously Trump would pardon Michael
Flynn if he could get away with it
Ty Cobb the White House special counsel
said Friday there's no consideration
being given to pardoning Michael Flynn
at the White House you know what this is
code for you know what we'll see is code
for it's code for if Flynn has turned on
Trump and is going to be informing
Robert molar about possible crimes
committed by Trump then no Trump is not
going to pardon him if Trump ends up
unscathed by the investigation and it
turns out Michael Flynn doesn't screw
Trump royally then yeah Trump will
probably pardon Michael Flynn I think
it's testing the waters too because
if Trump does eventually part in Michael
Flynn then the media story I mean that
the whole idea behind this is that he
had been thinking about it all along of
course not a big surprise when it
actually happens and that's why I
believe that this is this is gonna go on
for years more than likely right Trump
said recently this will end by the end
of the year yeah that's in like ten days
that's not gonna happen I would be
shocked if it wraps up during 2018 but
let's say it wraps up by the end of 2018
then you're going to have the trials if
not everybody pleads out then you'll
have potentially pardons if Donald Trump
doesn't get taken down this is going to
go on for years no matter what at this
point and there's talk about impeaching
Trump already I think it's a little bit
premature
I agree but if he does part in Michael
Flint I think you have a constitutional
crisis on your hands and probably it's
justified to impeach Trump that's the
question which is even though pardons
are legal of course
are there certain pardons that could
contribute to an obstruction of justice
case and that I mean but that's way
above my pay grade legally speaking and
we'll eventually talk to the actual
legal experts about that